¿Qué hace el señor Mañueco con nuestro dinero?
Si recibimos 1 200
millones de euros más
y el presupuesto solo crece a 745,
nos tendrá que explicar el señor Mañueco
por qué está haciendo caja
con el dinero que le llega del gobierno de España,
por qué no lo destina inversiones,
¿por qué no lo destina a contratar más médicos?
¿Por qué no lo destina a los jóvenes
para que no se tengan que marchar?
Por tanto ineficacia y corrupción,
la demostración de 1 proyecto fracasado
y eso sí, 1,4 millones
de euros
del dinero de todos los Castellanos y los leoneses
para que el señor García
Gallardo esté calentito en la vicepresidencia
sin ninguna competencia.
Estos presupuestos
ponen en evidencia la Gran mentira de Mañueco,
donde siempre ha dicho que bajando impuestos
aumenta la recaudación.
Es 1 fiscalidad completamente
elitista que beneficia solo a quien más tiene,
a quien más dona y a quien más hereda.
No son unos presupuestos,
son no son unos presupuestos inversores,
no son unos presupuestos que ayuden al campo.
De todo este dinero
y de todos los presupuestos de Mañueco,
¿cuánto VA a destinar a corrupción?